et puisqu'on est dans les bons plans on
va rester sur les bons plans avec ce
fameux personnage
marie thérèse garcin sans qui nous
n'aurions pas ni la morphine ni llyod il
est né vous le disiez tout à l'heure
xviiie siècle a dit jean et il est à
l'origine de la découverte de lieux et
de cette fameuse morphine et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des des plaques de rue à son
nom un petit peu partout en bourgogne
franche comté
oui tout à fait alors il s'agit de
bernard courtois à qui l'on doit donc en
1811 la découverte de llyod mais aussi
cet antidouleur qui l'a découvert
quelques années auparavant en 1804 qui
est la morphine
alors bernard courtois quand donc il est
fils a fait des études de pharmacie et
il ira travailler donc à l'école
polytechnique à paris au laboratoire de
chimie avec louis jacques thénard et
donc à qui il va d'ailleurs confié des
échantillons de cette découverte
ces deux découvertes cette lionne
1 d'abord ce ca de l'ior découvert la
mode alors avant la d'abord découvert la
morphine en 1804 et puis en 1811 llyod